this is the Ingram angle from Washington
tonight between a rock and a hard place
that's the focus of tonight's angle
now they're calling him a stand-in for
Biden in 2024 a political star waiting
in the wings who sure has been acting
like a candidate lately
going on the road to take the fight to
states where freedom is most under
attack so I'm here in Montgomery Alabama
we have a lot of work to do to build a
movement to counter what's happening in
red States across this country I'm here
in Sarasota Florida at new college and
we're here just to remind everybody of
what's happening in Florida and other
states like it
course as he seeks to raise his National
profile he's been playing very Coy with
the Press
because it's not my ambition it's not
the direction that I'm leaning into it's
not the moment so one way to answer that
question is I will never run for
president of the United States can you
say that yeah I'm not I have no interest
under any circumstances would you get in
this memory no
first remember as governor of the most
populated state in the country it's easy
to get lots of favorable press coverage
but when you're running for national
office people actually want to really
look at your record
Donald Trump and Ron DeSantis can
genuinely point to policies that worked
but Newsom according to the public
policy Institute of California which is
nonpartisan 66 percent believe there are
bad times for California ahead in the
new economy year 62 percent think the
state is already in a recession 61
percent say they're experiencing
financial hardship and 45 percent are
worried about not being able to pay
their mortgage or their rent
gosh no wonder why 4 out of 10
Californians are now seriously
considering leaving the state
but wait if Newson became president
where'd we all move to I mean Poland
Hungary anyone where would we go the
whole country would empty out now
extrapolating from Newsome's personal
popularity in a state run by democrats
and he's pretty popular there
extrapolating from that to viability for
national office over Joe Biden is unwise
first remember the real reason Biden was
the nominee in 2020
he was the only Democrat still alive who
the party could use to mask how radical
they'd become
remember the party picked Biden over
Bernie bootage Kamala Etc
none were acceptable to the masses but
Biden was
and even with his Dreadful economic
record to many Biden remains endearing
even reassuring wearing his banker-like
suits from the 1950s his Aviator Shades
and his perfect pocket squares he jogs
memories of the Democrat Party of yore
and when he reminisces about the good
old days millions of Democrats do too my
dad used to have an expression I swear
to God that's what he would say not a
joke he said Joey remember
but jobs about a lot more than a
paycheck it's about your dignity I had
an Irish grandfather named Ambrose
Finnegan and he used to say that when
you give a toast and you don't have any
alcohol in your glass you must do it
with your left hand
you think I'm kidding I'm not
no I don't think you're kidding just
increasingly enfeebled
68 of Americans are now fretting about
Joe Biden's mental Lucidity and his
physical health which includes 43
percent of Democrats were worried about
it that's up from just 21 percent of
Democrats just three years ago
now one main argument against Biden as
the nominee is that he's incapable of
explaining his record and the Democrat
agenda a sign in a law a once in a
generation investment over a billion 200
a trillion 200 billion dollars people
got laid off so did everything from
refrigerators to cell phones all told
we've created more than twelve thousand
twelve thousand jobs since I took office
yet at the same time a big argument for
Biden is that he is incapable of
explaining his record in the Democrat
agenda now let me explain what I'm
talking about Democrats know that there
are huge advantages to having a
figurehead who can barely talk as their
nominee because the Press won't bother
asking Biden any hard questions
sure because they're biased but also
because they know it's pointless it's
like talking to a piece of Styrofoam our
office management budgets played a major
role along with Mitch Ron Mitch Landrum
and our on our infrastructure
coordinator
but president but the secretary blanken
had a great trip to China having Railway
to go all the way across the southern
two thirds from the Atlantic Ocean to
the to the Indian Ocean in Africa
now they actually prefer that to a
Democrat trying to justify the party's
Fringe race and gender Obsession or
defending his party's handling of the
Border it's really indefensible it's
better to have the mumbling Biden
certainly in voters in places like
Virginia or Georgia they just want an
economy that works for the middle class
they don't want lies about how binomics
is working
makes
good sense by Dynamics right it kind of
flows off the tongue really well
certainly it's a vision right it's a
vision about growing the economy from
the middle out the bottom up it's a
vision with no results
now as bad as that was it's still better
than Joe trying to make the case that
you're better off than you were when he
took office
over the past two years we've gotten an
awful lot done together
we got a lot done together
so let's keep it going we have the most
vibrant economy in the world right now
in the world
well No One Believes this which is why
given the emergency the Democrats have
now broken the glass and dragged Barack
Obama out according to Politico Obama's
been meeting with the Next Generation
Democrats like AOC and Maxwell Frost
Obama even showed up for lunch at the
White House today
and while it was closed to the Press we
can only assume he got a hero's welcome
like last time
and anytime Barack and Joe were in the
same room you know what happens
thank you
Vice President Biden
vice president
that was a joke
it wasn't a joke and you see how small
Biden looks next to Obama who's a really
good politician Biden always looks
diminished when Barack Obama's on the
scene now other Biden Alternatives JB
pritzker of course of Illinois Gretchen
Whitmer of Michigan they're going to run
into the same problems that Newsome will
face if they ever threw their hat in the
ring of course in a class of unlikable
and untalented all by herself Kamala
Harris who was always trusted with the
most important assignments
have you ever been to Stonewall I am so
excited well don't be embarrassed he's
gonna tell you the Banger of the summer
okay that you need to play for your
people and they're gonna love it
everybody's gonna go crazy
foreign
[Music]
and then there's the laugh enough said
so Democrats really are between a rock
and a hard place here they'd probably
like to dump Biden but For Better or
Worse they're stuck with them even
though the hardcore activist base of the
Democrat Party hates most American
traditions our history and our Founders
there are still Democrats who haven't
drunk the neo-marxus Kool-Aid and there
are millions of Independents who just
want things to go back to normal
which doesn't include trans peacocks
parading around naked near little kids
and if you're scratching your head
wondering how Biden could still mobilize
any voters remember this
he'll do only carefully choreographed
campaign events
let's spread the faith folks folks thank
you all so very very much thanks
okay and
God Bless America thank you
um
when do we play that game where we throw
the big ball back to each other
plus most Americans don't follow
politics like you do and they don't even
listen to what Biden actually says
so from a distance Biden can still pass
as someone from the old Democrat Party
the one that didn't hate America that
didn't think being a devout Catholic is
a hate crime and that thought criminals
actually should be prosecuted not
coddled
right now it's like buying a box full of
air nothing inside is worth anything but
it's all they got and that's the angle
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else